ciao a tutti i titoli the tourist oggi
il nuovo episodio della challenge
preferiresti che cosa tesoro test di
personalità challenge preferiresti
questo quello insomma come la volete
chiamare di un rider in inglese bbc
serventi stimola prima che ho fatto ma
anche la seconda
vi piace tantissimo vedere cosa
scegliereste borsa sceglieremo noi vi
che senza correggere i commenti perché
ho visto che amy commentato sbizzarriti
già un tipo 2000 con me ma anche a noi
ci piace leggere le vostre risposte
vedere perché avete scelto quella
risposta quindi come si gioca noi
andremo a fare delle domande in cui
dovrete scegliere o una cosa o l'altra
la dovrete scegliere nei commenti e poi
noi daremo la nostra risposta siete
prodi e di comunione
mettetevi comodi prendiamo i pop corn e
iniziamo subito allora numero uno preme
rieti al dei primi sposare qualcuno che
non ami oppure perdere un dito o meglio
c'era un pezzettino ma scoprire allora
galli consigliere sposare qualcuno che
non avevo perdere un dito non è facile
però la parola dito mi fa male ma se i
massi certamente non è da qualcuno che
non amo e poi dopo come faccio a
mangiare senza un dito
è stato d'animo vita con qualcuno che
non ami dopo la cambio direi anche se
molto traffico perdere un dito perché
secondo me se ti sposi con qualcuno che
non ami per di più di un dito certi la
bacchetta mercato la felicità per di
tutto quindi osservo perdere invito mi
mancherà ma almeno per fortuna che noi
abbiamo dato la scienza ci comportiamo
12 preferiresti non mangiare per due
giorni a non avere il telefono per due
giorni e cosa perché non posso stare
fermo rapaccini visto che mai proprio
mangiare sappiamo già la risposta al
telefono per due giorni guarda che
lascia pure al computer e variate e voi
cosa scegliereste scrivete nei commenti
numero 3
preferiresti essere nudo per 10 minuti a
scuola oppure nudo un'ora per strada o
mio dio tanto mi è mai successo c'è un
incubo ricorrente che succede io qualche
volta l'ho fatto in cui vai a scuola
tipo in mutande
oppure ti dimentichi le scarpe scrivete
nei commenti se vi è mai successo che
non è mai successo di pensare queste
cose no io ho avuto incubi più terribili
di poter rimanere senza cibo per la 10
minuti l'incubo per porta a morano dopo
strada d'estate stai ok questo anche se
pensate restano in forno e quindi vedono
più persone per strada però
assolutamente
il prezzo fisso l'ascoli una strada una
strada più tranquilla rispetto a
prendere il sole del padre che dice che
quello adesso incerto anche io
sceglierei quello perché sarebbe più
imbarazzante se mi vedessero dieci
minuti a scuola le persone che conosco e
che vedo ogni giorno più che un ora
questa persona sconosciuto e perotti ti
vedono più persone voi cosa scegliereste
numero 4 preferire che la john pelle
sin.pa ovunque
oppure avere brufoli su tutto il corpo
per tutta la vita
sono terribili queste sei matin ha fatto
male 6 ma la pella che si allunga sì
anche se vedo quella perché non fa parte
i brufoli e immaginabili per carlo per
tutta la vita ad un po andranno via per
averli per tutto l'anno i costi per
tuttavia genere non è un po vanno
riaperte per tutta la vita magari no
voi cosa scegliereste scrivetevi
commenti è perchè scrivete anche il
perché c'è insomma a meno che non tratto
così nessuno ma ti prendono per un
braccio rimarrà però si tirava la pelle
di come si chiama big milan per quattro
per quattro
[Musica]
presumo che mentre i commenti come ti
chiamo in erano tre super eroi allora
non avevo 40 3
895 scegliere tua mamma o scegliere un
milione i no ma che domanda strane che
stesso cioè sceglie tua mamma non posso
cambiarla capisco e avete capito il
senso credo però la questione dei soldi
mi piace perché io a scegliere i soldi a
prescindere perché anch'io perchè non ha
senso seguito mamma voi cosa
scegliereste mora 6 preferiresti essere
povero mai innamorato oppure essere
ricco è single è secondo me ci sono
delle variabili cioè perché è ricco e
single potreste essere ricco e single
potrebbe sembrare una scelta un po però
secondo me non è da sottovalutare è
innamorata ma che non spara ricco perché
sono innamorata
tra un po ricamo nadal io sceglierei la
prima perché se sei ricco estinguersi
comunque su persone
la prima la seconda è perché ora 73
ferite serie bannato da internet per il
resto della sua vita oppure dormire lo
scheletro vero per una settimana
ma chi cavolo di noi del toro essendo
dormire
anch'io ho dato che ti può fare più vivo
però sicuramente degli incubi li fai
turno anche se arriverà una politica
vera vita rete internet e tu sei uno
schiavo anch'io bortone segnate scrivete
ricompare 8 prevenire è vivere nel mondo
di star wars che sarebbe guerre stellari
oppure vivere nel mondo di harry potter
ma che domande ovviamente vivere del
mondo di alimenti
a parte che un mondo bellissimo
gianni vivere nel mondo di harry potter
e c
e voi quale scegliereste e ora un ricco
tra green vista le piace tantissimo
hagrid 9 preferirete veri prurito per la
fitta aiuto
oppure essere amici foto per il resto
della tua vita di essere appiccicoso
l'immagine insomma può vedere nella
gomma masticata quindi forse io
sceglierei essere appiccicoso sarebbe un
po brutto tipo organi stringi la mano
qualcun altro senza però avere prurito
previsto nato ricetta è continuamente
possono quindi essere pizzicato ziosi
raid razzista robot in estate la foto
alle 10 ma vorrei fare scegliete è
perché numero di stare a casa per sempre
non ammalarti mai oppure viaggiare in
tutto il mondo è ammalarti per ogni cibo
che mangi o mio dio è terribile
però nel cibo che mangia non è possibile
queste cose però non si è indecisa
preferirei stare a casa e non ammalarmi
mai almeno so che potrei continuare a
fare la cosa che mi piace prendere degli
animali le nozze che non potrò mai giard
anche io preferirei stare a casa
soprattutto basta
[Applauso]
vorrei quale perché diretta scrivete nei
commenti
11 preferiresti crescere un bambino
orfano o pesce un cucciolo di cane molto
carino oddio ma sono due cose
completamente diverse
c'è ovviamente
mi dispiacerebbe lasciare il bambino
orfano orfano però in questo momento non
siamo pronti ad essere un bambino per
effetto un momento non ci sentiremo
pronti quindi che useremo un cucciolo di
cane ma saremo voi cosa scegliereste
rumore 12 preferiresti non usare mai più
di social media
oppure non guardare mai più un film o
una serie a in questo momento non le sei
film stanno andando alla stragrande un
po difficile
qual è la vostra serie preferita
però io devo comunque scegliere non
guardare più film o serie perché non
potrei stare senza youtube senza di voi
ha visto che la mostrano gialli di
whatsapp tutto il suo arresto quindi
quindi non riuscirei a stare senza ma
son mica quindi servono guardare film e
serie tv finalmente così non possiamo
andare a dormire perché a volte anch'io
su netflix
a precederli un film
se vuoi preso gli air act scrivete nei
commenti e perché no al 13 preferirsi
vivere l'esperienza dell'inizio della
terra quindi big bang immagino oppure
della fine della terra
oddio cioè di fare la fine sarebbe un po
traumatizzante però sarei curioso di
vedere come finirà salgono a fine anche
se sarà brutto è traumatizzante voglio
vedere come finirà tu mi incuriosisce
alla fine però scegliate l'inizio perché
alla fine sicuramente mi porta senza
penso che vedere alla fine significhi
anche alla fine di lui stesso quindi se
magari vedo l'inizio
vuol dire che cioè non solo vedo
all'inizio ma ho la possibilità come
dice vito di guardare dinosauri tutto il
resto
magari finire in pasto un dinosauro così
pino veramente mi piaceva sopravvivere
stili anche mettere a parte le cliniche
di sì proprio all'inizio poi scegliete è
perché non un attore di chi preferiresti
avere tre bambini e non è niente soldi
oppure avere niente bandone avere
bambine famiglia però avere tre milioni
di dollari
dipende c'è ma significa che lasciano un
bambino un milione di dollari sempre un
milione di dollari perché un 8000 fermi
tutti da chi potrebbe anche essere
allora dipende cioè nel senso in questa
situazione attuale non riusciremo a
crescere va bene volto però pensiamo del
futuro tipo futuro non avere mai figli
avere 3 milioni oppure avere tre figli
non avere soldi bavero del bambino è
sicuramente un futuro senza avere soldi
per pazienza
anch'io salvo quello perché sarebbe
molto triste non avere i bambini non
possono fare più po triste e poi isolate
proprio 600 con i soldi ma ancora non si
è capito che avere tanti soldi non vuol
dire che sei felice perché se hai tanti
soldi e sei solo non te ne fai niente
voi cosa scegliereste è perché cosa
interessante numero 15 preferiresti
essere la persona più divertente al
mondo oppure essere la più intelligente
e molto difficile per la tele gente
all'integrazione certo conoscendo per
andare sul simpatico
io penso che se gliele intelligente vi
dispiacerebbe non essere divertente però
sarei contenta di sapere tante tante
cose saper fare tantissime cose
voi cosa scegliereste con 20 a 16
preferiresti essere in grado di correre
a 120 chilometri orari
quindi velocissimi timidissimo prima
velocissima per perinetti riuscire a
correre
oppure riuscire a volare ac 10 miglia
orarie che sarebbero fermano al 12 13
chilometri orari
ok allora io penso a pensarci nemmeno
salvo volare perché il mio sogno è
sempre fatto di riuscire a volare per
sognavo admirable aree livello e
biglietti
perché mai viste le tante orbita resi
dalla finestra con pappagallo prende il
volo
non so come facciano 17 preferireste
avere una terribile memoria terribile
memoria a breve termine oppure una
terribile un orribile memoria a lungo
termine e quasi sono due esempi di due
cartoni della pixar
avete visto il primo enemo in cui c'è
dori che si dimentica sempre tutto e
l'altro è sideout l'altro inside out c'è
un altro esempio della memoria perché vi
ricordate che sono terzo amori libera ci
sono anche bruttissime memorie li
vedessi n'è qualcuno che faccio adesso
non voglio una brutta memoria bravo
neuer ibile memoria a breve termine che
dimentico tutto cosa fare la spesa per
spesso di presentare come sei
ma certo dimentico tutto il cielo un
orribile e memoria a lungo termine
perché le cose recenti mele devo
ricordare non riesco a organizzarvi se
mi dimentico le cose recenti quindi
sacco qui quel giorno si sveglia dirti
che sei tu voi quale segnate
questo è molto difficile scrivetemi como
lora 18 preferiresti sapere come morirai
oppure sapere quando morirai via degli
eletti cioè se il libro credo cioè mi
piacerebbe sapere quando piuttosto che
come perché come mi pare buona in
un'ansia breve di fare quelle
determinate cose che fece sapere quando
pensi tranquillo se questa frittata però
è scritto le sue tra di grillo però sa
che secondo me sapere quando può essere
molto rischioso perché prendi delle
scelte in base a quello e magari cambi
un pò la tua vita in base a quello ma
non avresti dovuto come abbiamo visto
troppi feriti
io preferirei sapere come almeno magari
cerco di vita cioè se dico che se c'è
scritto voi annegato se gli comunque
quando voi cosa scegliete è perché
dovrebbero essere sicuro non fate foto
mangiare l'ausilio di mezzi per abolire
la lega si butta erano tutte le domande
non si sa bene se volete vederne altri
ne faremo un altro episodio nesi
divertiamo sempre un tempo appare ci
posso vedere il voto e risposte
se volete continuare a vedere ancora
come la vostra personalità e come la
nostra cliccate qua per vedere gli altri
video in cui facciamo le nostre scelte
difficilissime cliccate qua oppure
cliccate qua qua ho qua per vedere i
nostri altri video
lasciate un bel live se volete vederne
altri e buona visione